how did your favorite game of thrones
stars really feel while they were
filming some of the most dramatic
intense moments in the series
here are the scenes that the cast
absolutely dreaded filming
and a few that certain actors refused to
take part in altogether
warning season 8 spoilers ahead cersei's
walk of shame through king's landing in
season 5
was brutal enough to make audiences
sympathize with one of the most
diabolical characters in the entire show
to atone for the sins of adultery cersei
was forced to walk naked through king's
landing while the citizens verbally and
physically assaulted her
although many game of thrones stars are
used to wearing nothing but their
birthday suits on camera
actress lena heady chose to work with a
body double for the scene
rather than bearing at all hidy said
that the scene would have involved three
full days of shooting sans costume
and she didn't feel that she could
accurately portray cersei's emotional
state if she herself was exposed the
entire time
hidy is also a mother and she noted that
stripping down for certain scenes
might bring up some awkward
conversations with her kids haiti's
usual stand-in rebecca van cleeve
agreed to appear nude in the scene with
hidy's face superimposed on her body
in response to claims that she was less
of an actress for preferring to keep
herself covered he he had to stand up
for herself she told entertainment
weekly
you know what it was really a bit
shocking i've done nudity i'm not averse
to it
but i know i'm a very emotional actor
and i get really driven by that
the game of thrones season 6 finale had
every fan on edge
the season went out with a bang
literally rather than attend her trial
with high sparrow
cersei decided to pull off an
unexpectedly devious revenge plot
she set the entire sept of baelor ablaze
with wildfire
a highly flammable and rare substance
that gives a whole new meaning to the
phrase
scorched earth lancel lannister tried to
save the day in vain
while in a tunnel under the sept he
notices three candles burning in a small
pool of wildfire
and he attempts to reach the end of the
tunnel as fast as he can to blow them
out
due to his injuries he can only crawl
and he does not make it in time
actor eugene simon said this was his
most physically demanding scene the
directors had him spend the entire day
crawling using only his upper body
strength throughout he told elle
i had to do it 27 times by the end of it
i was covered in sweat from exhaustion
by the time i got to the fire i felt
like the hulk
euron greyjoy is one of the most
frightening characters of game of
thrones
he has no moral converse and there seems
to be nothing he won't do in pursuit of
the power that he craves
even among the other ruthless game of
thrones characters euron possesses a
unique form of evil
actor palou asbeck plays the role
perfectly yet in real life
azbek is nowhere near as frightening in
fact he was actually intimidated by one
scene in particular
in the game of thrones universe every
kingdom has their own unique rituals and
ceremonies
when a new king is crowned in the iron
islands a drowning ceremony is part of
their initiation
of course filming something like this is
complicated and there's no way that the
cast and crew are going to get it right
in one take
azbegg said that filming the drowning
scene was quite a struggle
after all it's not easy to act while
you're freezing cold and unable to
breathe
aspect told l when you're underwater and
there's a guy pushing you down and it's
very very cold
it's one of those challenges that you
have to accept as an actor this is what
it is
this is what we're going to do
wearing unique costumes and makeup on
set is just part of the deal on game of
thrones
to create some of the special aesthetic
effects actors have had to wear coloured
contacts and prosthetic lenses
for example after arya stark goes
temporarily blind in season 5
maisie williams had to wear coloured
contact lenses for a few episodes
until her sight was restored but she's
not the only character on set who had to
spend a little time in the dark
the marin trans death scene in season 5
the cast and crew began shooting early
in the morning
and actor ian beatty recalls getting
prosthetics in his eye
around 9 00 am that day unfortunately
the prosthetics basically left him blind
for a full day of shooting and he had to
leave them in for a full
12 hours he says that all he remembers
from that particular day of shooting was
total darkness from morning until night
he remembers his death scene as his
biggest challenge on set viti told elle
it was in many ways quite a surreal day
it was very technical
but maisie and i had worked it out in
rehearsals and we were ready
tormund giantsbane is a fan favorite on
game of thrones although he is arguably
a relatively minor character
he's gotten more and more screen time
throughout his tenure on the series
to the point that it raised something of
a fan uproar when his fate was left
ambiguous in the season seven finale
he's a tough character and maybe gruff
at times but beneath his rough exterior
there's something endearing about him
actor christopher hivu has appeared in
plenty of crazy battle scenes where it
seems like it's hard to keep track of
anything happening on screen
if you admit that by the time you were
scheduled to shoot the season 7 finale
it had enough of working with the whites
the whites that audiences see are
actually a small crowd of extras with
the majority added digitally in
post-production
regardless the actors had to keep up
with quick choreography
and according to hibiu the scene pushed
him to his physical limits he told elle
in the beginning it was tough but in the
end it became a kind of horrible dance
it was extremely exhausting ellaria sand
and her daughter tyene had one of the
most frightening death scenes in the
entire series
and not a drop of blood was spilled
cersei handcuffs both ellaria and tyene
to opposite walls of a dungeon
and then poisons tyena's revenge for the
murder of her daughter marcella
forcing ellaria to watch her own
daughter to die while she has helped us
be stuck to make matters worse
cersei promises to keep allaria alive
for some time solely for the purpose of
torturing her
and prolonging her suffering allaria
actress indira varma said that she and
roosevelt's sellers who played tyne
struggled with their hand curves
throughout the entire day of filming
since they were supposed to be fighting
against them the cuffs would
occasionally come undone but at other
times they got stuck in them
vama was one of the last people on set
that day and she found herself unable to
get out of the cuffs
finally a crew member from the props
department discovered a solution
varma said in an episode of games
revealed literally at the end of the day
i was like
may i can't get it off can someone help
me and everyone's gone pete from props
is like
i think we need a saw and i had to be
sawn out
amelia clark said that filming
daenerys's final scenes was heavy but
one scene much earlier in the series
really pushed her to her limits as an
actor in season one daenerys eats a
horse heart during a dothraki ceremony
the scene looks painfully realistic
and many viewers probably wondered what
clark was actually eating whatever it
was
it couldn't have tasted that great
clarke wasn't chowing down on real
bloody meat but the feast wasn't much
more appetizing
she has to eat the whole heart
i hope that wasn't my fault she's doing
well
the horse meat was actually made out of
solidified jam and clark said the flavor
reminded her of a nasty combination of
bleach and raw pasta
in fact she said she was so grossed out
by the taste that she barely felt like
she had to act in the scene
and unfortunately this was not the kind
of scene that she could just get over
with in one take
shooting lasted for several days and
clark said that she was physically ill
she told the mirror i ate roughly 28
hearts throughout the days we filmed
that scene
fortunately they gave me a spit bucket
because i was vomiting in it quite often
when jon snow and daenerys finally met
in season seven
it was obvious that there was a spark of
instant chemistry between the two
characters
and anyone could have predicted that
they would fall for each other romance
was definitely on the horizon
at first it seemed like destiny fire and
ice were coming together at last
but in true game of thrones fashion they
couldn't simply hook up and then live
happily ever after unbeknownst to either
of them
jon is actually a targaryen by birth and
daenerys is his aunt
needless to say actor kit harrington had
some mixed feelings about the scene
after years of working on the show
harrington and clark are good friends
and filming a romantic scene together
was undoubtedly going to be a little bit
awkward
plus knowing their character's family
lineage harrington thought that john and
daenerys were making a mistake
both actors relied on humor to keep the
situation a little more light-hearted
i like looking at it and going oh god
i'm sorry
through our game of thrones so many
different characters have come and gone
and there are always several major
storylines going on throughout the known
world so it's only expected that some
major characters rarely appear in scenes
together
for the most recent seasons this has
been the case for bronn and cersei but
it's not because their characters don't
have any connection
after all bronze spends plenty of time
with jaime lannister
cersei's twin brother and not-so-secret
lover it's actually because bron actor
jerome flynn and lena heady used to date
and the breakup must have been fairly
tumultuous because both actors refused
to film scenes together
flynn and hidy nearly had to share a
scene in season seven when almost all of
the main characters convened at the
dragonpit summit
however attentive viewers may have
noticed that brad and cersei didn't even
share a second of screen time
bronn made a quick exit and excused
himself for a drink before cersei
arrived although the two
split before late 2014 when hidy began
dating a current partner
the wounds must still feel fresh but
perhaps they will have to set their
differences aside for the final season
after all bronn is now supposed to be
leading the lannister army
and working for cersei so it will be
interesting to see how the directors
work around this dilemma
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
game of thrones are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]